en ce moment en france la polémique fait
rage autour des violences policières sis
déjà durant les manifestations des gilet
jaune les violences policières avaient
fait la une de l'actualité
l'agression du producteur michel est
claire il y a quelques jours à paris a
relancé le débat samedi dernier à paris
des rassemblements ont eu lieu contre la
loi de sécurité globale qui voudraient
interdire la diffusion des images de
policiers
un défilé qui avait aussi pour but de
dénoncer les violences commises par les
forces de police
cette dérive autoritaire ça suffit
plusieurs personnalités avaient témoigné
de leur soutien après l'agression de
michel éclaire notamment les
footballeurs antoine griezmann et kylie
ann m bat p mais aujourd'hui gérald
darmanin utilisent ces mêmes vidéos pour
dénoncer le manque de soutien des
policiers qui se font agresser le
premier ministre en est pris directement
aux footballeurs oui je trouve que
certains ont la dignité sélective
une façon pour lui de ne pas seulement
condamner les violences dans un seul
sens
alors êtes vous d'accord avec le tacle
de gérald darmanin contre qu'il ya des
maps et antoine griezmann vous êtes
d'accord avec le tacle de l'iran normal
un sachet et vous pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez même s'il savait que voilà
et que antoine est un pote et que je
n'embrasse port d'ailleurs si nous
regarde antoine griezmann
vous êtes d'accord frank tapiro bien sûr
ah oui bah oui parce qu'à un moment il
faut condamner tout ce qui est
condamnable donc évidemment cette action
contre une chose est claire c'est
épouvantable on ne peut pas non plus
passer ce silence et 97 policiers qui
ont été blessés lors d'une manifestation
c'est absolument incroyable quand on
sent pas policier on frappe en force et
enfin pas citoyens donc ce sont nos
représentants dans l'espace public donc
tolérer une exaction est fermée lisez
sur une autre ça c'est absolument
vraiment éprouvante n'a pour moi satine
non alors c'est pas parce qu'ils n'ont
pas tweeté sur le passage à tabac des
policiers qui tolèrent l'action c'est
juste que je pense qu'elles sont plus
les mots qu'on sent en fait ils se
soutiennent entre citoyens donc
forcément ils ont tous été pour michel
parce que c'est entre citoyens et
malheureusement les policiers jeudi pas
du tout j'ai pas envie que mes propos
soient déformés dans les médias
dit pas qu'il faut vraiment abbas et les
policiers mais je dis juste que va les
policiers c'est leur métier ils sont
dans la confrontation dans ces choses là
et ça veut pas dire qu'il faut les
ramasser ça veut juste dire que ils vont
forcément soutenir beaucoup plus michel
et vont pas faire un tweet pour chaque
personne tapas et non plus j'ai vu hier
pour une demi heure michel je peux vous
dire où on peut soutenir michel on s'est
parlé ça mais chaque lecture des
policiers c'est ça aussi soutenu un
michel qui soutient les policiers c'est
un supporter qu'on frappe 97 cantine et
ça m'a donné des airs comme mon pote est
fière de ce vent qui soutient les
policiers alors qu'il a été il a été
déjà subi une agression il soutient les
policiers passent et les travailler avec
eux et qu elle est adressée qu'à 95%
ils font leur travail et que comme j'ai
dis à chaque fois je le dis à chaque
fois les tout ce qui arriva et les les
bavures policières
ça fait mal aux policiers surtout et
c'est ça qui me fait de la peine parce
qu'il ya 95% de mecs qui font bien leur
travail ils sont pollués par 5 % de 2,2
de cowboy oui alors déjà gérald darmanin
on sent qu'il est un peu le sommes
contre les footballeurs ci commence en
disant les footballeurs millionnaires
donc bien quand vous voulez avancer
votre phrase comme ça si vous n'allez
pas être très objectif
ensuite c'est à dire cette phrase qu'on
dira jamais sur vous les chroniqueurs
millionnaire et ensuite chroniqueurs se
trompe de débat ils se trompent de débat
mais ce dernier n'a pas ce que les
footballeurs ils ont traité certes pour
la violence qui a subi michel lam il ya
aussi du racisme dans cette agression
est parce qu il aurait été traité il y
aurait eu des insultes racistes et faut
que le racisme c'est un sujet qui leur
tient particulièrement à coeur
c'était malheureusement il ya beaucoup
de racisme dans le football je pense
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est une
personnalité on a le droit de choisir
sur quel sujet on s'exprime on s'exprime
pas mais ils se sont exprimés contre ça
et c'est tout à leur honneur 1 billion
raison oui pardon sert il
mais une fois de plus il ne faisait que
répondre à une question d'alba ventura
qui a mis le problème sur mais sur le
feu cette histoire a mis le feu aux
poudres
et c'est normal y'a pas de souci
là-dessus et il ya même pas de débat
seulement c'est son rôle aussi de
recadrer un peu les choses et d'apaiser
un peu la situation mais là c'est pas un
baiser
oui mais si parce que quelque part ils
ont une puissance médiatique aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux ces personnes là
oui ça peut ça peut envenimer les choses
donc oui il doit aussi recadrer un peu
la situation
mais colas mais à la raison et ça
devient de plus en plus en jeu c'est
cette histoire du pour ou contre qui
fait qu'il n'ya plus de débat est
aujourd'hui c'est trop facile comme de
fer détruite comme ça et de ne rien
proposer en échange les gens aujourd'hui
critique tout
mais personne ne propose deux solutions
et on en est même arrivé là au niveau
politique c'est ce qui est catastrophe
pour le pc catastrophe de kelly mais est
ce que tu penses vraiment que le que
justement le débat il a sa place là ce
débat là mais aujourd'hui on n'a
strictement rien à faire de ce débat là
je pense qu'ils la commande autre chose
à s'occuper que ceux d'hier lui la suite
et lui la quantité cela n'a rien on met
cette fois ben c'est donc sur les et
magali c'est pour peut-être et 10e dire
d'apaiser la haine justement c'est
balance tombait le soir exactement
formidable
ils sont évidemment l'ambition hier soir
sur la dessus aïe ça en fait les titres
et impulsif dans quelqu'un quitte huit
études sur le moment en fonction de sa
voix donc si tu veux tu étais par
rapport à ça ils ont droit les
footballeurs après ce qui dit le
ministre moi je trouve qu'effectivement
ajouté millionnaire sa charge
t'as pas besoin de dire mais
footballeurs millionnaires mais c'est là
que ça change tout et je trouve que la
mission d'un ministre de l'intérieur
c'est ne pas diviser ceux qui
soutiennent mais violences faites aux
lié oubliant tous les siens chacun est
libre de s'exprimer par rapport à son
propre ressenti par rapport à sa propre
émotion mais il est pas le mot
réalisateur de la france l'arme annoncé
le ministre d'intérieur sous-entendre il
a souvent 30 quand même tapé et
griezmann sont pour la vie la réponse
allait hier soir dans balances ton post
et je suis pas et j'en ai pas besoin
jules un truc derrière un mec qui leur
dit qu'ils se devaient d'être avec qui
travaille avec la police et qui se fait
donc boxer dans sa bagnole exulte
remercié le maire sur le plateau digne
commerciaux vrac et l esprit qu ils
expliquent qu'ils travaillent avec la
police qui respecte la police sauf que
le mec il s'est quand même pris des
coups dans la gueule pendant cinq
minutes parce qu'il dit là il ya un
débat il ya un débat illinois vaille le
rhin il ya un débat ils s'expliquent
tout le monde s'explique et on retourne
la plus intelligente c'est formidable ce
que j'attends de ça sont des débats
aujourd'hui faire juste un tweet sa part
isis à paradip l'action des
gouvernements mais ça fout le bordel
regardez aujourd'hui
plus personne ne peut rien faire dans
ces ministres on est soit rallongé
ministre attendait débattre c'est cet
acquis et je sais ça exactement
non il a juste dit qu'il fallait que ce
soit équilibré et qu'il fallait aussi
tweeté de temps en temps mais la police
et non mais il est quand même mba pays
griezmann s'est des héros nationaux
c'est des gens qui font rayonner
rayonner la france à l'international il
aura bien tourner comme le temps de
soutenir une cause qui est noble et de
défendre le mali s'est fait tabasser par
ce fonds dans cette dimension n'est pas
sélective elle est subjective c'est à
dire qu'on peut s'indigner pour telle ou
telle raison ils n'ont pas être les
porte paroles s'ils ont envie de tweets
et pour une cause il le vin et quand le
gouvernement naissant digne pas on ne
dit pas que c'est sélectif
alors oui à 49 pour son nom à 51 me dit
c'est un homme politique ça sur 49 % c
est normal mais parce que vous vous êtes
vous